françois legault chef de la coalition
avenir québec merci d'être là capsules
web
j'en ai fait quelques-unes dans d'autres
comme sujets d'actualité cette semaine
le sujet d'actualité
la deuxième proposition vis et un marché
aux états unis avec semble peut-être que
ça pouvait marcher avec nous sommes ici
30 c'est françois legault les autres
partis vous dont associé à lui attend ou
à raison à tort transport que jamais
j'ai dérapé comme monsieur fin ça presse
les baisses d'impôts ça près d'ankara
dry l'immigration pourrait trop haut
pour rester au niveau la population que
des préoccupations des populations
donc en ce sens cela même je le ferai
pas comme 8 faut tirer une leçon
nos élites doivent tirer une leçon tout
le monde était surpris black grogne de
la population
ce week end vous avec vos membres vous
tenez un congrès de la coalition venir
québec la cac et vous présentez vous
suggère aux membres d'adopter un article
un peu comme le pq qui définit la place
du parti politique de votre parti
politique dans le canada nulle part dans
cet article on voit la moue fédéraliste
au québec le bout fédéraliste est
associée au statu quo on utilise les
mots qu'on voudra on veut un québec plus
de poids qui en prend tous les pouvoirs
pour défendre sa lame ses valeurs son
identité mais à l'intérieur du canada
votre cheval de bataille c'est
l'éducation n'est ce pas prouvé une
chose que voudrait changer qui ferait
une grosse science sa sera commencé à
s'occuper des enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage
la mesure la plus forte qui est proposée
par la cac c'est d'étendre la maternelle
80 ça nous permettrait de détecter le 15
pour cent d'enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage de leur
donner des services plus tôt si on veut
réduire le taux de décrochage
pour commencer il faut commencer tôt
quel est l'état de l'intérêt que vous
faites des jeunes à l'égard de la kek
l'éducation l'économie
je pense que ça change beaucoup les gens
voient d'abord si je suis en politique
c'est pour les jeunes manger deux fils
de 22 24 ans je peux tellement fier de
ce que je leur reste comme société et
qui est très bien merci
ça va me dire voilà c'est très agréable